[Music]
together again at last
these were the scenes at sydney airport
in early november when australia
reopened its international borders after
almost 600 days
[Music]
the country's zero covert strategy came
at a cost
melbourne capital of victoria state had
six lockdowns
but as the state reaches its 90
vaccination target
life's now becoming difficult for the
unvaccinated
only those who've received the jab are
allowed to visit restaurants gyms and
most stores
i'm ben fazeland hi australia's always
been cut off from the rest of the world
but during the pandemic it literally
closed its borders and stopped most
people including me from coming in or
going out
as a result covert has hardly touched
the country but aussies have had to
endure long lockdowns
barista theo rosus is finally back at
his espresso machine
melbourne is just waking up from its
sixth lockdown which lasted 260 days
during that time theo had to lay off 20
employees
now he hopes to be able to start hiring
again
if you look at it
from saving numbers and keeping the
covert cases down absolutely worth it uh
from a business perspective
the opposite because it wasn't worth it
obviously the help wasn't
was just to keep us open or functioning
to be able to open we made no money
during the lockdown no one did
meanwhile his client nick deftaros is
fed up with lockdowns he says many
people have suffered mentally from the
restrictions and sought refuge in
alcohol or lost their jobs no one's
talking about that side of things
you know people's freedoms have been
taken away
some people have willingly thrown it
away very restrictive on movement and
everything it's pretty much like an
open-air prison here in australia
a few houses away hairdresser darren
williamson has his hands full
he's glad the government was so cautious
because he suffers from an autoimmune
disease catching covet could have been
fatal for him he thinks it was a smart
move by the government to relax the
rules in line with certain stipulations
like the recent vaccination requirement
it's been a very difficult couple of
years
but with the high vaccination right it's
i think it's motivated people to get
vaccinated because we want to get out of
it more
you know and
i think that'll stand us in good stead
for the future
the city of melbourne was growing
rapidly before the pandemic now many
people have moved away captain jimmy
gantidis has only worked a total of
three weeks in the past 20 months we're
his only guests today
australia enjoyed revenues of around 28
billion euros a year from oversea
tourists before the pandemic began
but up until now non-citizens were not
allowed to enter the country except
under special circumstances
by new year i hope international travel
comes back
tourists come down people having parties
again
that's what we need people to be happy
to be free
to live life don't be scared
that's what we want back to the way it
was
meanwhile theo roosus would like to
reopen his indoor area to guests but one
thing worries him from now on he has to
check if his customers are vaccinated if
he doesn't he could face a fine of up to
70 thousand euros
uh the culture down here has never been
that way it's always doing our doors are
open uh wide open for everybody to come
and again i if i had a choice
i would accept vaccinated and
unvaccinated people that would be my
choice
in melbourne they hope that this time
the lockdown is now finally over
at the beginning of 2022
australia is expected to open up again
to tourists from europe and when it does
melbourne will welcome them with open
arms
but will those arms have been vaccinated
let's talk about australia's policies
with catherine bennett who heads the
epidemiology department at deakin
university's faculty of health in
melbourne
historically a country of petty
criminals and as we heard they're an
open-air prison according to some i mean
what sort of good or harm has has it
done locking up all those aussies for so
long
oh it's had very different effects on
you depending which state you live in
victoria's really had the hardest run
with this and the longest time in
lockdown of course and the most severe
lockdowns with also the highest fines
and penalties associated with it and so
you find people that actually are now
still even though we're opening up
scared to leave home because they think
if it requires that level of restriction
that they should still be worried and
there are others who were over locked
down a long time ago and and we saw that
in protests and so try to manage
expectations keep people in the middle
where we're still doing things safely
but also allowing for the fact that
we've got people with very different
views and very different experiences in
the population catherine what's your
assessment did xero covert work
well it kept our infection rates even in
victoria the most
troubled state in terms of waves of
infection we're still looking at the
infection rate of something like 1.5
percent of the population very low and
of course we kept our death rate
incredibly low by world standards so
that did work whether we did it all
uh as perfectly as we could i think we
need to do a lot of evaluation work to
really understand where we could have
pulled back a bit and still had that
same outcome but um
what has happened in this year is we
started off very slow with our vaccine
rollout probably partly because we did
have this almost complacency with those
international borders closed but once
the virus the delta variant came
on
on site and we had to deal with it and
knew you couldn't close it down easily
as we had previous variants that then
was a game changer and that then pushed
our vaccine roll out to now you know
amongst some of the highest rates in the
world from something that was very slow
starting that's been a good outcome and
that small percentage of unvaccinated
that's right there's still um in some
states and territories you know we're
getting down to very low numbers some
states less than five percent of people
12 and over um
our two most populous states victoria
and new south wales are looking to be
well under 10 of people 12 and uh 12 and
over vaccinated other states are a bit
slower
we are seeing in victoria that
two-thirds of our current new cases
are people who are unvaccinated so
we're hoping those numbers will be small
enough
and of the people remaining unvaccinated
that there will
have been a number of people who have
had the virus by now and and actually be
you know have some natural immunity so
hopefully that that division based on
vaccination status will become less
relevant as the numbers are very small
of people who don't have any immunity
and does it help that summer's there now
i mean the fact that uv
light is a a lot more abundant down
under
yeah well that's right and i think you
know the timing has worked for us where
we've rolled out just coming out of our
uh spring and in fact it means that at
the time we started to open up in new
south wales and victoria 50 percent of
people were still within the first
month or two of their second dose so
we've got that booster time where you
get the best
outcomes from your vaccine where you've
got the best protection from onward
transmission not just serious illness
but any infection so we've got the
benefit of that as we wind into summer
and as you say you know there's a lot of
things about summer including a tendency
to mix and meet outdoors more often to
use outdoor areas in in hospitality and
so i think we will like the rest of the
world enjoy
a slightly less
pressurized period over the summer
anyway and then we'll be looking at our
booster program going in to early 2022
for the general population as well and
that should set us up i think well for
autumn
catherine one more thing what about
protecting businesses we heard in that
report about all of these small
businesses and bigger ones two folding
during the pandemic
there has been a lot of support for
businesses trying to keep them going you
know we know that the stress um the
financial stress for the workers as well
as the business operators and owners is
enormous and there's a big public health
problem in its own right so there has
been a lot of work to try and keep
businesses holding together job keeper
programs so that staff could be paid and
so
that's the reality that will hit now
though as people start to open up we do
actually need people to be getting out
and and participating in retail and in
those businesses to get them back on
their feet so i think it's one thing to
survive it's another thing to actually
have a profitable business and so i'm
hoping that as we do open up over summer
we do it safely and that helps these
businesses get back on their feet
because it's been a devastatingly long
series of lockdowns i don't know what
the count is i think it's 270 days in
victoria so an extraordinarily long time
to try and survive without you know with
disrupted business disrupted schools so
much going on that we now have a long
recovery from
catherine bennett deakin university
great to have you on the show
thank you
germany's vaccine advisory committee
known as stico is now recommending covet
19 vaccine boosters for all adults
this comes as the number of infections
in germany hits a new record the
committee says the top-up shot should be
administered with either the modino or
fisa biontech vaccine it said a booster
should be given five to six months after
the last dose
time for our science correspondent derek
williams and a viewer question about
comparing vaccines
i am vaccinated with johnson johnson am
i less protected than if i had been
vaccinated with another vaccine
well that depends on which vaccine you
want to compare it to and straight up
comparisons are tricky territory anyway
so
in addressing this question i'm only
going to focus on what the centers for
disease control said about the topic in
a publication from september now in this
big study
the researchers didn't look at how
effective the three different vaccines
approved in the u.s were
at preventing breakthrough infections
overall and those who were vaccinated
instead
it took a stab at estimating risk of
hospitalization
when an otherwise
generally healthy vaccinated adult
somehow got infected with covet 19
anyway
and since risk of hospitalization has
become a really key metric
as our stretched health care systems
head into another pandemic winter
that makes sense to me i think that the
most important takeaway was that
although the vaccines approved in the us
provided varying levels of protection
against hospitalization
for all three
that protection was still considered
substantial
in percentage terms however vaccine
effectiveness was estimated at 71
percent for johnson and johnson and
around
90 percent for the two approved
double-dose messenger rna vaccines the
authors therefore said that the data
indicated
they provided more protection than the
single shot johnson and johnson vaccine
but they also hasten to add that there
are several limitations to the report
not least that as i said
it looked only at hospitalizations and
not overall vaccine effectiveness
another important thing to remember is
that in many countries
people who got the johnson and johnson
vaccine
are now being urged to get a booster
within a couple of months and and that
will almost certainly increase
protection and recipients
even more substantially at least
in the medium term
so nice to have you along stay safe and
see you again soon
[Music]
you